modern gender Siri is not based on
science gender was used dramatically for
a long time it's wordplay and it's based
on the hypothesis that was tested in a
very evil way from a very evil son of a
[ __ ] question of the day before moving
to topic question of today do you
remember where you were or when it was
rather that you were told for the first
time gender and sex are different
comment below I'd love to hear from you
because there's actually a very new very
modern thing do you guys remember where
you were I was on the show really last
couple years you were on 14 those 15 see
in German school women's school to a
more progressive people we learned that
in school okay
I learned it I think I learned it in
college actually coming to a magnet
school near you yeah well the reason
this matters now a lot of people aren't
really aware of and it will put this
here in five minutes
five minutes or less so you can
understand the entire history of modern
gender theory and how it's been
differentiated from sex and it's a new
thing it's not a real thing so the left
now they're they're absolutely going
nuts over the Supreme Court right
they're saying at this new pic that it's
going to destroy trans rights that's the
thing right now they're tunnelled what
the ratification is the transgender
community so the sex the sex / gender
the distinction is a foundation of
modern sort of gender fluidity the
ideology it's you know this I know this
it's very recently though but accepted
as as Dogma you teach this you teach
trans study so if you would give us a
brief cherian Studies on so many gender
identities that in your view require
non-traditional pronouns basically it's
not correct that there is such a thing
biological sex and it's something that
subscribe to each of us at birth in
relation to our bodies when you're born
you have no say and what gender you'll
be raised as yes I'm not saying what you
eat and you also poop uncontrollably or
any other sexual decisions at that age
let alone chopping off your penis so
this is something that you hear it all
the time you hear talked about in school
and this is the pre this is this is the
the crux of a lot of these new laws of
pronoun laws of compelled language but
you don't generally hear about the dark
history of this concept was pretty
recent French existentialism is is where
it came from was a woman named Simone de
Beauvoir I think was let me bring it up
right here yeah 1949 who famously said
one is not born but rather becomes woman
her book is the second sex you can go
read it
now here's in the it supportin this was
the MA it was a theory this is where
start kind of the philosophy of gender
as a social construct but it was still
within this idea that the binary concept
yeah that you could be raised male or
female and that was the concept that
wasn't tested it was a hypothesis that
maybe it's socially conditioned now here
is what you learn in college here's what
all of the modern gender books are based
on it comes after someone above all this
goes to sexologist psychology on money
took this one set for the test of the
hypothesis in the 50s and 60s and this
is his hypothesis that he tested which
was based on Simone de Beauvoir was a
sex with biological gender could be
socially conditioned okay so he tried to
test this theory on a baby boy b-b-boy
Dame named David rhymer you probably
read about this in college lost his
penis in a botched circumcision attempt
oh here's a clip to give you more
context it is also the story of the
psychologist who treated him a man with
a radical theory about what makes us
male and female masculine and feminine
he's brilliant I think John is a
brilliant man I think he's one of the
handful of most brilliant people I've
ever met
together but they helped further one of
the most famous flurries in the history
of modern psychology that a boy
any boy could be raised as a girl okay
and this was something that was touted
as a really tremendous success right
remove David's testicles raise him as a
girl so the treatment that people don't
understand right he had this get kid had
a twin brother yeah that's also
important the idea was taking twin this
is the famous twin study you've probably
heard it to it referred one raised boy
one raised going twin boys treatment
social conditioning to turn and then it
was considered success in Todd in
college what they don't tell you is that
actually a part of the treatment was
having children assume sexual positions
to reinforce their gender roles money
even took pictures of them doing that I
normally get put in jail for that you
would think so or in this case really a
book deal you get your own sub-genre of
study see there you go yeah and I went
about this all wrong BuzzFeed bully
ladies talk about it so uh he published
the papers right on David's cases proof
gender was a social construct and this
was then it was it was celebrated all
across academia again this is the crux
of the modern gender / sex delineation
here's were separating gender and sex
because of the twin study from janmani
the problem is that David of you can
we'll get to in a second he didn't feel
like he was a girl right and he actually
began living as a boy around 15 years
old when the true history of what had
happened to him the child abuse is some
of us referred to but we lose our
speaking gigs like Nino and Benjamin the
Chaldees was revealed to him he started
living as a boy I had Barbie dolls
clothing but my brother was very
generous there's the odd day when he let
me borrow his toys we played together
there's anyone happy I was so he let me
play with his toys for Brenda this was
the first time in her life she started
to feel happy she said she wanted to be
a boy so I said okay are you sure
because there's no going back after and
he said yes I he said yes I am sure that
is what I want to do okay
shedding the female persona of Brenda he
was forced to portray my confusing if
you're you sure you want to go back well
the mean go back is he was a boy then
the guy had him being humped by his
brother two teeth telling me that he was
a girl and they said but actually your
boy do you want to go do you want to
just be what you were born
that's the question there how did this
end up again because it was taught in
college for years access it's still why
gender theory is taught it's still why
gender studies exist it is based on a
lie well David's brother Brian became
schizophrenic overdosed on
antidepressants
he died David then himself blew his head
off with a sawed-off shotgun by the way
that's not a cry for help that's someone
with some follow-through got someone who
wanted out let's be really clear about
this if you wonder why the trans suicide
rate is so high it is literally based on
the the figurative petri dish of trans
studies yeah the hypothesis was tested
in a controlled lat
okay two twins raised one as a boy
raised one as a girl they said success
papers get published degrees get given
out on this topic and then when one
blows his head off with a shotgun and
the other Odie's hush-hush let's not
talk about it because the ends justify
the means but if it's all based on a lie
and then this was taken from the 80's
90's post modernist thinkers Judith
Butler you probably learned about in
college took this idea based again you
can read about it
Judith Butler cites money that gender is
a social construct and then try to turn
that into gender fluidity an infinite
number of genders so that was really
that was really only introduced in the
90s even John money to screwed up way
still believed that he could turn a boy
into a girl and roll into a boy it was
this this this pansexual fluidity this
guy who was making kids mount each other
yeah and dry hump and Levi's would have
thought that was absurd yeah he would
even blush it how many letters we now
have at the end of this thing and I hate
to do the whole like the whole
conservative see the Lib tardes there
wall
they're fake signs they're they're into
science I hate doing that but in this
case it's like they are at the party of
pseudo-scientists you branch this out to
intersectionality and all kinds of
theories of other oppressive classes and
how they it's it's faked I mean it comes
down it comes down to does the end
justify the means and for them the end
justifies the means are we broken down
the gender bear and people are free to
be trans well okay let's say we agreed
with that the trans suicide rate doesn't
get better pre post surgery and it
mimics the original study that is that
was the precursor for any and all
current gender studies it shouldn't be a
surprise if you know the history and a
lot of people don't this is it if you
trace it back it all goes to the twin
study modern gender theory is not based
on science gender was used dramatically
for a long time as I speak French and we
could apply to the word pot right it
could apply to the word spoon there's
masculine and feminine nouns so this
idea it's wordplay and it's based on the
hypothesis that was tested in a very
evil way from a very evil son of a [ __ ]
and the problem is that's the basis
that's the root those chants occur if
the roots are healthy the tree will
thrive I understand this is what's
happened this guy was a Chauncey
gardener only everyone from professor's
to City Council people to sitting
senators governor's and possibly your
next president use this logic we've
encountered all the time
doctors will play God and make a
decision about what biological sex each
child should have and so they perform a
surgery noise like in terms of a
physical manifestation right sure so
then why should they have to choose I'm
a male or a female if they were not born
a male or a female okay so you're you're
saying that male and female is a gender
not a sex yes you're confused on the
idea of gender versus sex I'm confused
okay yeah okay so when we say there are
only two genders we often confuse the
idea of gender in sex
shorts is a generalization of X Y
chromosomes not as confused as a kid who
was forcibly dry-humped by his brother
while his doctor took pictures as part
of a science experiment which is what
you base your information on now from
which you draw your degree not quite as
confused as that so when people try to
play that they try to do the wordplay
game you don't have to go along with
them just you don't need to know three
people C Mon de Beauvoir
money Judith Butler boom their argument
is gone try it see if it does not do
wonders for you by the way on a related
topic according to a new study published
in the Journal of female scientists
American women have the biggest breasts
in the world so that's nice after the
fourth of July this is just another
story in a long line of stories that
there's I know there are some clouds out
there in the news but you don't have to
look for silver linings this is still
the greatest
[Music]
okay
[Music]
we've turned the tables on Al Gore and
use the internet to our advantage if you
liked this video subscribe by hitting
the subscribe button or the notification
bell next to it because subscribing
isn't enough watch one of these other
videos and you know listen you can you
can stick around you don't have to but
here's the thing the fact that you're
still listening to me saying stick
around as I say stick around and you're
sticking around the BAA we just added
another add you just made me for more
sense